here on our show we love all things
design i am a design junkie i'm a solver
i believe don't renovate innovate
and we also love our environment and
conserving resources
um for the next generation i am a mom
with two kids i wish i was as awake as i
should have been um i am now and i'm so
excited uh that we're gonna discuss
something that's happening in our world
that is so on trend for all the right
reasons please welcome our next guest
she's an expert and an entrepreneur she
is the upcycling expert who blew up this
year on tick tock showing us all how to
give second life to everyday items
please welcome to the show sarah
tarasinski
[Applause]
by the way
what does upcycling mean to you how
should we be thinking about that term
well i think upcycling for me it started
out of a necessity because many moons
ago um i was a single mom and i wanted
to have things for my baby girl that she
could wear so i started taking my old
t-shirts and making her dresses and then
i would go thrifting and i would want to
design a room because i couldn't afford
anything else so for me at first it was
necessity and then it became about you
know i ended up getting married and
having more kids and i'm like i have
this whole little crew of people and i
really need to keep this moving for them
and now it's about so much more than a
necessity but i understand what it's
like to need it as a necessity but
there's so much amazing stuff already
out there and we should be using it
right i love reworking it having fun
with it gave a second life to items but
that you yourself had a second life as
well i know for real can i just ask real
quick what are we going to upcycle today
because i have a glue gun and i need to
use it okay
i'm being patient i want a crap he's
ready all right bring this home ross
thank you okay ross andrew we have two
upcycles today we're going to start with
number one and they kind of fold into
each other we're going to start with our
cans don't use a standard soup can just
a little bit bigger like those tomato
size cans oh that's what these are okay
okay take the top and bottom off so then
you take your wallpaper and you guys
just grab your pieces of wallpaper you
peel it off because drew has the easiest
peel-and-stick wallpaper thank you
i appreciate it and then we got it
look at that that was so easy i know oh
my god then you just bring your paper
around right you kind of center it and
if you if you mess up the corners it's
no big deal you can just come through
with an x-acto knife and this is team
this is team this is t look yes yes i
did it you did it then what you do so we
already have a couple that are already
done for sake of tv so you guys have
these so what you want to do take your
glue gun
and just
line the two edges right here
just have fun with it and my motto is it
never has to be perfect you don't have
to make it perfect it doesn't have to be
but mine is and nobody notices
and nobody notices okay so then you turn
this this way and drew you want to put
some lines here oh happily yes and then
you just jam that sucker down on there
and it's hot glue so look i know
seriously i know i'm doing it and then
you you hold them in place just for a
few minutes watching your fingers and
then as soon as they dry usually give
about five minutes then you guys you can
slide your bottles in
this is so cute can you picture this
like on a bar cart you guys well ross
you i just uh redid ross's dressing room
and surprised him with it it's so
pretty i'm so glad because i i wanted so
bad to make you happy
um but he wanted a little bar cart so
when we realized we were doing this
segment with you
somebody got real excited ah so can we
can you help me make a bar cart but i
want to upcycle it okay well you are
upcycling it because it's a diaper
changing table and so just wheel out of
the nursery into your kitchen and
and repaint it we want to have the wrong
changing table yeah well these are so
great and these are all over
secondhand you guys you just cut your
paper and you cover if you peel it off
here and then drew you just match it up
in the corner again
it doesn't have to be perfect you can
always come through
and then just slide that down
you can always come through with your
x-acto knife and cut those corners ross
you're doing great yeah mrs t this is a
little harder than the can i just want
to say
it's really i promise you you're going
to have it loaded with stuff so even if
there's a little bubble in it just come
through and spread it out right
just like that get your corners okay so
this was in a thrift store and now it
looks like this yes
sold thank you so much yeah little
babies that's so
yeah isn't that so fun
then you can take your wine rack and you
can put it on there and then ross is
like oh i mean oh my gosh i'm getting
ready to like entertain
your thing looks way better than mine
ross well i wasn't going to bring it up
but now that you mention it yeah i know
but the good news is the bar card's for
your room not mine and you know what you
can actually set it the other way as
well you could put your napkins in there
you know what you could i can't you can
do oh
it doesn't there's no way i love that
exactly
right that's the whole point about
upcycling and crafting dirt shift major
what i meant to do
and they look great this is so much fun
and i cannot believe how easy it was so
easy and very fun
perfect i mean look at that cart that's
like the finished product wow that would
be amazing that's the goal
yeah that is goals right there
so fun thank you guys
thank
thank you that's going right upstairs
i think we'll take that one upstairs
yeah i want the one that she did okay
thank you yeah you do
[Music]
you